he's saying like women you know that's
my property you have to think about it
like this like when you have your
husband right or your man you want him
to claim you right you want him to
protect you like he's your pro like that
you're his property you want him to take
care of you you want him to maintain you
you want him to go above and beyond
because you're his so again it's
literally just the context of it but
mind you in order to get through to some
of these gentlemen you have to have that
locker room talk and I think he's able
to get through to some men and there are
some men who just take it overboard and
they disrespect women and they don't get
the message he's trying to come across
um but I think it's the way the message
is being delivered so I like to
especially with the podcast we have and
the different people we have whenever
people say things and I maybe get
triggered or I may be emotional about it
I take a step back and I'm like why does
that bother me right where's something
in me that's bothering me that I feel
like offended by this